انتشرت هذه الأغنية الأوكرانية
على نطاق واسع في أوكرانيا وما وراءها هي قصيدة
لطائرة بدون طيار ،
يعد سلاح الباريكتار التركي الصنع الذي
يروج له المسؤولون الأوكرانيون
أحد أكثر الأسلحة فعالية في ترسانتهم
التي لعبت دورًا في إبطاء
التقدم الروسي
الذي حققه بايركتار tb2  كانت تعمل
لسنوات وصفت بأنها تغير قواعد اللعبة في
النزاعات الأخيرة مثل ليبيا
وناغورنو كاراباخ ، لكن أوكرانيا هي
التي دفعتها إلى الشهرة العالمية ،
ونجاحها ليس فقط في
مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بضربات
أهداف عسكرية روسية مثل هذه
التي أصدرتها وزارة أوكرانيا  من الدفاع على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي جعلها أيضًا جزءًا رئيسيًا
من حرب المعلومات في أوكرانيا ، فقد
حصلنا على وصول نادر إلى منشأة الإنتاج هذه
هنا في تركيا ولكن
نظرًا لطبيعة هذه الصناعة ، فنحن مقيدون للغاية
فيما يمكننا تصويره وما
يمكننا القيام به  show
seljuk beric dar يعطينا مبتكر الطائرة بدون طيار
جولة خارج الكاميرا في الغالب
في مقر شركة Bay Car Defense
في اسطنبول.  فخر Pany's Pride Kizzle
alma turkey أول طائرة مقاتلة بدون طيار
وصلت للتو إلى خط الإنتاج ،
لكن النقطة المركزية هنا هي الطائرة بدون طيار التي
يتحدث عنها الجميع عن biologtar tv2
وهي طائرة بدون
طيار تكتيكية من فئة الذكور
وهي تقوم بما تم تصميمه للقيام
به وما تمت ترقيته للقيام به  في هذه
المقابلة الحصرية على قناة سي إن إن ،
يقيس بريختار كلماته بعناية ، فهو
أيضًا صهر الرئيس التركي
الذي يحافظ على علاقات وثيقة مع كل من
روسيا وأوكرانيا ، وقد ظهر
كوسيط رئيسي
كما تعلم ، لا أريد التباهي
بالتكنولوجيا  عندما
يضحى الناس بحياتهم ،
يقاوم الناس ويدافعون عن وطنهم
ضد احتلال غير شرعي ، فهذا ما فعله
شعب أوكرانيا الشجاع
وقيادتها في نفس
الوقت بالطبع ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى التكنولوجيا
التي تحتاجها أنت تعرف التكنولوجيا
العالية وتحتاج إلى  القدرة الدفاعية الأصلية الخاصة بها ،
ولكن
عندما تكون حياة الناس
على المحك وعندما
يكون الأطفال يموتون حتى
يموت المدنيون ،
فأنا لا أريد ذلك  مقارنة
ذلك بأي نوع من أنواع التكنولوجيا التي
كانت مبيعات تركيا للطائرات بدون طيار إلى كييف
مصدر إزعاج كبير لروسيا قبل فترة طويلة من
هذه الحرب ، حصلت أوكرانيا على أول طائرة من
طراز bairikdar tb2s في عام 2019
، وقد طلبت 36 طائرة بدون طيار على الأقل
حتى الآن ،
ولكنها ليست مجرد عميل تنتجه
محركات للطائرة بدون طيار akinshi الأكثر تقدمًا
وكان على وشك البدء
في إنتاج خطط الطائرات بدون طيار التركية التي
تعطلت بسبب الغزو ،
سمع بايريك دارز الأغنية المخصصة لطائرته التي
تحمل الاسم نفسه ، وهو يعرف
جيدًا الظاهرة التي أصبحت عليها في أوكرانيا ،
وأعتقد أنها
واحدة من  رموز
المقاومة وتمنحهم الأمل ،
أعتقد أن
[الموسيقى]
الأمل في معركة يقاتل الأوكرانيون
على جميع الجبهات
، تعد طائرات الدببة بدون طيار جزءًا من
حملة وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الأكبر التي
ينفذها الجيش والمدنيون الأوكرانيون بشكل جيد للغاية.
خلق انطباع بأن الجيش الروسي
يخسر في الواقع وأن
الجيش الروسي ضعيف مرة أخرى ، فإن
باراكتار ليس هو الحل الوحيد
هناك و
إنه ليس بالضرورة حلاً سينقذ
الجيش الأوكراني لأنه بعد كل
هذا حرب برية ولكن وجود طائرة بدون طيار
مثل ثكنة في السماء يمكنها
إجراء مراقبة يمكنها شن
ضربات وتضاعف مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بهذه
الضربات الاجتماعية.  وسائل الإعلام هي
معنويات معنوية كبيرة ، وهي أيضًا انتصار تكتيكي كبير ،
كما
يظهر مقطع الفيديو هذا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مدنيين
في مدينة هيرسون يحتجون ضد
القوات الروسية وهم يعزفون عليها أغنية باي
راختار ،
وهي واحدة من لحظات المقاومة التي لا حصر لها من
قبل أمة تستخدم كل ما لديها.
يجب أن يقف في وجه الغزاة